doing that Lady Rebels are your Mountain
West Conference champions there they are
hoisting up the trophy and they played a
pretty exciting game against Wyoming
yesterday defeated the cowgirls 71-60
and it was their 30th straight win so
now they go dancing NCAA tournament
there we go so while all eyes were on
the lady rebs last night and the men as
well something incredible happened in
the whack tournament which is also
happening here in Las Vegas so much
basketball happening here but check this
out a buzzer beater Southern Utah taking
on New Mexico state
it's knocked away still loose Doherty
the heave
[Applause]
oh there you go down by less than two
four seconds left Thunderbirds hit that
miraculous shot they won and the final
score was 62-61 we love those buzzer
beaters and boy they're about to be part
of everyday vernacular here as March
Madness gets underway all right